i want to get started right away so uh i
want to start with cryptocurrencies
obviously bitcoin has been running we've
crossed that 60 000 psychological
threshold nfts are all the rage right
now crypto punks we've got many other
nfts as well uh jordan i want to start
with you
where do you fit in like how do you
explain what the heck it is that you do
to an average person when you're at a
party like a kid's birthday party or
whatever how do you possibly explain to
people what cryptocurrencies are and
what it is that you do when 68 of hedge
fund managers don't feel comfortable
enough to invest in crypto because
they're clueless about it
yeah so first thanks for having me kevin
it's a great question the way i like to
think about it is crypto's like a cap
table there's never going to be more
than 21 million bitcoin i was part of
the founding team of coin called hbar
which is part of the hedera hashgraph
network there's lots of tokens in the
market but really what makes crypto
unique is that it's scarce uh so uh the
first piece when people are coming into
crypto obviously they want to
accumulate as much as they can of the
underlying protocols that they still
think are going to be here in 5 10 15
years
but beyond accumulation beyond just
owning crypto in your portfolio i'm a
firm believer we have an asset
management business we advocate that
people have some percentage of their
portfolios with exposure to
cryptocurrency we believe there's so
much more so what amiibo holdings our
whole philosophy is don't just own
cryptocurrency own the blockchain and
what we mean by that is take exposure to
really exciting businesses building in
the blockchain space so there's publicly
traded bitcoin mine companies like uh
hut a and riot and hyde that you can
take exposure to coinbase is publicly
traded uh voyager digital
uh galaxy digital these are publicly
traded blockchain equity place investors
can take exposure to so we're big
believers and beyond just holding
cryptocurrency which is interesting and
exciting and i hold some and i know uh
mr wonderful here hold some uh it's
really important to diversify through
blockchain equity and that's uh
i'll get at that for the cocktail party
i gotcha okay so uh kevin o'leary i want
to know last time we spoke we were
worried about blood coins in china
essentially with dirty mining and
potentially separating clean mining from
from dirty mining and how those clean
coins could be more valuable now we've
seen china essentially exit stage right
and now they've banned transactions and
mining in china how does this affect
your view of investing are we now
worried still about finding clean coins
versus not or can we just say hey let's
invest money with jordan into something
like immutable holdings and get exposure
across the board maybe even own
cryptocurrency directly where do you
stand on that now
well let me address the esg issue
because you've brought up three
different elements there so esg issues
not gone away it's one of the reasons
that major institutions are waiting for
a resolution to it and there is one
emerging and it's simply this there are
many pools of capital being accumulated
to develop mining operations in places
like western texas
or in the nordic countries where they
can use a combination of solar and wind
to mine coin and provide electricity for
the grids in those regions and the idea
there is along the hot 8 line that
jordan mentioned
hud 8 one of the reasons i own that
stock is that the ceo there a woman
named jamie leverton has committed to
her shareholders that she will keep
those coins that she mines sustainably
on her balance sheet so an indirect way
for me to own the coin knowing with
certainty it passes my compliance
committee that is looking at esg issues
sustainability issues ethics issues and
no different than many large
institutions or sovereign funds and
indeed her stock trades with the
volatility of bitcoin so it's an
indirect way of solving that problem and
there's at least four or five other
projects uh one of which i'm getting
involved in that's going to mine
sustainably in western texas so that i
think that resolves itself for the next
30 40 50 years and so we'll see more and
more institutional uh involvement china
was forecasted i mean they're they're
trying to keep centralized control there
so bitcoin bitcoin doesn't fit into
their world or nor does just crypto and
and they're trying to launch their own
digital
chinese currency of which the chance
anyone else is going to own that is zero
so it's it's uh they're in a bit of a a
squeeze box there because in order to
mine the efficiencies and productivity
that
you know decentralized finance promises
and cryptocurrencies promise to reduce
friction and cost and be a global
solution for a lot of financial services
you got to be part of it so if china
wants to just do their own thing that's
fine
but they won't get any participation
from anybody i mean the reason i would
never own
that coin is i don't know who's watching
and i'm pretty sure it's going to be the
chinese government so why would i let
that happen
to any of my assets so i think they're
going to get a lot of pushback and i'm
just one voice and i'm sure they'll come
around at some point now regarding
owning immunoable
my attitude about owning crypto and the
whole sector is
i have a discipline of diversification
i'm forced by mandate here to never have
more than five percent in any one stock
this is on the equity portfolio or never
more than 20 in any one sector and
there's 11 sectors in the s p 500. i
consider crypto to be the 12th sector it
hasn't been deemed that yet by the s p
but it's coming
and so my view is how do i get
diversification well
jordan's company hold as the symbol i'm
a shareholder is diversification it's a
series of assets on the chain so why
wouldn't i want that to me it's just i'm
investing in software productivity
software i invest in google i invest in
in microsoft why wouldn't i invest in
immutable holdings same thing they're
all the same to me and that's how i'm
going to trade it
now would you end up uh jordan i want to
ask you when you're investing in uh
various different blockchain
technologies or minors how are you
balancing how much you're putting into
minors versus uh let's say altcoins or a
blockchain tech one of the things that i
also notice is sort of a follow-up and i
want to actually hear an answer from
both of you on this is i noticed that
with crypto miners uh they a lot of
their value is in that they're holding a
lot of their own cryptocurrency they're
holding their own bitcoin for example i
interviewed the ceo of hud 8 and she
talked about how grateful they are that
they are hodlers of bitcoin but you're
paying six to seven times the market cap
of the actual uh bitcoin they're holding
so you're putting a lot of trust in that
technology infrastructure they have on
actually mining bitcoin so i want to see
how do you both value this how do you
value the bitcoin miners and how do you
value these different blockchains you're
investing in like you said jordan you
got to find the ones that are going to
be here in five to ten years so i want
to start with you jordan and then we'll
go to kevin
yeah so beyond just accumulating crypto
what we bri
and a lot of people have made a
tremendous amount of wealth just
accumulating cryptocurrency and are
sipping my ties on probably beaches not
too far from the one i'm i'm close to
right behind me but beyond doing that
there's a really
there's a really great investment
approach and we put this together this
is our operating thinking at immutable
holdings which is
what are some of the businesses that we
could build that extend awareness access
and adoption of blockchain technology
and digital assets that are native to
them so you're absolutely right kevin
people can take exposure to public
equities that have indirect exposure you
can buy micro strategy stock michael
saylor has a huge amount of bitcoin on
his balance sheet there's a there's a
website called
bitcointreasuries.org which actually
published publishes a list of publicly
uh traded um stocks that have bitcoin or
crypto assets on their balance sheet uh
and yes you're going based on multiple
but for someone that doesn't know or
isn't competent in managing a public
private key pair
that's a really great alternative to
actually owning crypto at immutable
holdings we're doing something very
different today we actually don't have
cryptocurrency in our balance sheet what
we're building are profitable businesses
our breakout blockchain brands like
nft.com and 1-800 bitcoin we're building
businesses that uh
bring our awareness access or adoption
to the space so to give you an example
1-800 bitcoin it's a toll-free number
we're going to provide mass-market
education to people who call that number
and provide them with bitcoin master
classes and research products on the nft
side we ourselves are adopting
underlying blockchain technologies and
on the asset management side we're
helping family offices and high net
worth individuals that don't want to
hold crypto native we help them take
exposure to funds that give them that
exposure in an indirect way and we make
money through management fees so we are
a way a diversified way to take exposure
to the entire sector
again i would advocate that yes crypto
is an interesting part that part of your
portfolio either holding it directly or
indirectly through the bitcoin miners or
some others you will certainly pay a
premium if you if you go that route as
you're pointing out but really
diversifying and owning businesses
coinbase is going to make money whether
the price of bitcoin is going up or
going down
they make money on volatility they make
money on fees that's what we mean by own
blockchain equity owned businesses that
are going to do well in a bull or bear
market cycle
okay and kevin o'leary what do you think
why why perhaps uh a fund that's going
to exp expose you to miners uh where you
are paying a little bit more of that
multiple as opposed to just maybe
holding the coins directly
well the expectation um
when you own the equity of the company
is that will become more and more
efficient
at mining coin and it'll get do a better
job at doing it and perhaps do it and
wears a lot of value in a sustainable
way i cannot own coin where i don't know
the providence because i also have to
serve institutions that are not allowed
to own coin that isn't sustainably mined
they have sustainability committees we
haven't resolved that yet so rather than
than get myself in a conflicted
situation i put the value in owning the
hot aid stock and i i've been buying her
stock for a while now so you know
in times of bear markets it traded as
low as six dollars and now i think it's
14 15 and that just reflects the price
of bitcoin's appreciation over the last
90 days and if the coin goes down so
will her stock so
but no one questions my owning that
equity
they understand that she has been mining
sustainably since she was awarded her
first coin so there's value there she's
also just recently raised another 150
million dollars i don't know what she's
going to do with it but i'm going to
assume she's going to use it accretively
because she's a good manager and i'll
benefit from that as a shareholder my
whole point is i don't need to own
bitcoin natively only i can own it in
other ways and i do own some native coin
that i know with its providence and so
for me it's i don't i don't need the
resistance and the headache and the the
compliance officer barking at me i don't
want that stuff and i don't i don't need
it because i have other businesses that
have to that i have to be compliant in
all the time so i'm no different than
many other institutional clients that
are concerned about this issue so
there's value in in many different ways
same with what's going on with immuno i
mean there's there's i have no
everything there is compliant so
you wouldn't believe how powerful this
compliance committee is becoming in so
many giant institutions
that's incredible i want to know from
both of you uh nfts i know immutable and
does a lot of work with nfts even nft
gaming's uh or yeah we're in the nfc
gaming space how do we see nfts uh
evolving over the next five to ten years
is this something that is like the 2000
uh tech bubble or is this something that
has lasting staying power and what makes
nfts different how should somebody
getting into nfts value one nft over
another start with you jordan
yep so kevin for your internet native
you're spending a lot of your time on
the internet i've been watching your
videos for years now for the generation
that's internet native and spending an
increasing amount of time online the
concept of buying an intangible digital
item is not is not to uh is not a
foreign concept for them you've got kids
that have been buying in-game swords or
currencies in games like world of
warcraft or runescape when i was growing
up actually used to sell runescape goal
points until the makers of the game said
hey stop doing that that's our
intellectual property secondary markets
have been forming around mmorpgs massive
multiplayer online role-playing games
and second life was one of the first to
actually and kevin mentioned compliance
get money transmission licenses state to
state actually second life still to this
day has money transmission licenses in
all 50 states and three territories they
have a currency called linden dollars
and they've been the market maker
essentially selling linden dollars and
land inside of that business so those
are nfts to some extent we've got games
like upland uh which is an nft game
where you can buy islamic uh inside of
it what we're seeing happen in nfts
right now it's manifested in the form of
art these jpegs these gifs these memes
that are going viral uh board apes
or crypto punks or women of wonder these
collections are incredible and people
are starting to figure out how to create
utility for a photograph for basically a
jpeg a piece of art we're starting there
there's no doubt that i i won't i won't
say where we are in the bubble if we are
in a bubble at all i think a lot of
people on crypto twitter will chew me
out if i comment on that but what i will
say is that
independent of of of of where we are in
the market cycle the opportunity for
nfps is so much more than just art and
intellectual property what literally
everything we have a value in the
physical world whether it's the title d
to a piece of property
like the office i'm in right now or
whether it's the authenticity
certificate to an fp journal or protect
the leap that mr wonderful wears on his
wrist on a shark tank episode quite
literally everything we own a value in
the physical world is going to be
represented in this digital world in the
form of a token and that given the
amount of time and increasing amount of
time that we're spending our lives are
digital online we've got things like
blue check marks that said know that
this is an influencer this is someone of
credibility this is someone who's on
shark tank uh given how much value we
put in these intangible items
an increasing amount of capital and
value is going to be stored in this
energy economy we're really proud to own
nft.com we absolutely are building ways
to onboard new people to the nft
ecosystem to help both creators and
collectors capitalize in this new world
and uh and we think marketplaces are a
great start so today we've got millions
of users in the nft ecosystem coinbase
has got 68 million users that they just
announced that they have we are very
much at the beginning of nfps very
excited about what the future looks like
kevin o'leary jordan just mentioned the
crypto community and uh you know
mentioning that if if we uh touch on the
potential downsides that there could be
backlash in the crypto community kevin
o'leary do you ever feel like uh you you
can't say anything wrong about crypto
without being attacked
yeah it's a very vocal community and
that's okay it's it's you know a lot of
the people that were the early founders
feel they have a proprietary
relationship with the community or with
the assets themselves and that's okay
too but
if you really want to see bitcoin at a
million dollars a coin this has to be
ubiquitous across all different buyers
whether they're involved in crypto today
or not and the potential to get there
and even see bitcoin at 100 000 by year
end is going to be an expanded market so
you know my view is there are many many
many people that have not yet
participated in crypto that over time
will become more comfortable with it
certainly gen z is very active there
millennials and as even some baby
boomers now see it as a store's wealth
and they're allocating some portion of
their net worth to it but at the end of
the day you know i look at it and say to
myself what drives
value in a market
is disruption and enhanced productivity
and so if you believe you can get
that out of cryptocurrencies
or decentralized finance it will create
value and you heard a use case that
jordan just referenced around watches
let me give you some more metrics to
that because i'm very involved in the
protocol to develop a standard for watch
nfts
every year there are 20 billion dollars
of transactions
in new and used watches they trade from
one hand to another they move from one
state to another when you have a very
valuable piece such as a patek philippe
or a vintage rolex or an fp journal
which is probably the hottest watch in
the world right now
before you purchase it in the secondary
market you have to get it authenticated
because you don't know with certainty
that it's real
maybe it's being held at a dealer in
hong kong you have to get it in bond all
the way to new york
have it looked at by representative
either the maker or or an auction house
that has these expertise to authenticate
it send it back to hong kong and then do
the transaction that is incredibly
inefficient and i've gone through that
for decades as i've built my collection
and i'm fortunate to know the world's
largest watch collectors they have the
same struggle the same challenge
collectively you know in conjunction
with some of the authorities that
oversee horology
we're working together to try and set
standards that then we can on right at
nft.com start to provide individual nfts
for each collector's collection
i want every one of my pieces to have an
nft associated with it that
authenticates it into my estate
even my insurance company wants that
instead of having to go through the
arduous process of having it
photographed
and all of the paper accredited i can
have all that
encased inside of an nft and simply send
it to the insurer and i'll get a
discount rate if i can do that that's
what they've told me already so
there's so many use cases for nfts where
the physical asset is tied to the
digital for the sake of authenticity and
efficiency
that's where we're going
that's incredible i mean it sounds like
uh kevin o'leary you're potentially
talking about soon
maybe individual investors even being
able to invest in a share of your watch
on something like nft.com am i going too
far on that or am i no no that's already
happened to me my watch that i wore the
white steel white face daytona with the
red band
went to auction last year at an
extraordinary price
and i only wish that i had the nft to
that watch because i'll never have it
again now i'm fortunate i was able to
buy another one but that watch was on
shark tank for 12 years that was the red
band watch and it has tremendous value
with fans and many others have asked me
do you have a picture of it i can have
so that's what the nft will be my plan
is to go back to the buyer it was a
charity auction for the one drop
association and ask him if he would
allow us to make an nft of that because
the demand is insatiable for that piece
now jordan kevin o'leary just referred
to bitcoin potentially going to a
million dollars as we sort of expand uh
how many people get involved in
cryptocurrencies and i think golly i
mean if you can invest in kevin
o'leary's watch via the blockchain
that's certainly going to expand uh
people's interest in cryptocurrencies
jordan how how are you folks getting
involved because i know nft.com right
now you've got coming soon your email
address you've got nft gaming you invest
in various different public companies
i'm trying to wrap my head around
what it is y'all do with crypto to me it
sounds like you do everything can you
touch a little bit on uh on on the
future of nft.com and uh is it true are
you sort of like a basket of everything
like forget about a bitcoin futures etf
you could have a bask a little sliver of
everything of cryptocurrency with you
so
the best way to think about immutable
holdings is that we are very much the
first to build the berkshire well we
like to get us the berkshire hathaway a
blockchain now berkshire hathaway is a
holding company with very diverse
holdings that aren't related to any one
particular industry or sector right
they own geico they've got large
holdings in america express and
coca-cola they own some apple stock or
at least it at one point and dairy queen
right nebraska furniture market added to
the list what we've decided is what if
we did what the interactive corporation
remember barry diller back in the 90s
building one of the first internet rate
holding companies with match.com ask.com
angie's list this was one of the first
internet holding companies around the
time of the dotcom bubble and and
there's a lot of strategic synergies
between
companies right you can share accounting
resources maybe you can share a cfo if
they're early stage
you can share engineering teams uh
different ways to build merchant
processing and checkout funnels there
are a lot of strategic synergies between
building blockchain businesses like
1-800 bitcoin nft.com and immutable
asset management we wanted and and today
are giving investors exposure to a
holding company that's got six
subsidiaries ranging from uh just
quickly the list is cbdc.com which
stands for central bank digital currency
hpar.com which is the symbol of the
hedera hashgraph network and network i
was part of the founding team of it's
number 35 or 36 or 37 on coin market cap
depending on the day
we've got an advisory business where
we've been brought in i've consulted
with the monetary authority of singapore
on on project ubin launching their
central bank digital currency
i've met with you know c-suite at google
ibm boeing deutsche telekom on them
putting together strategies and how
they're working on the space that's why
is our team monetized but our core
thinking really kevin is around
awareness access and adoption if you
want to own crypto that's amazing and
you can absolutely stop there like i
said and set my ties on the beach but
what are the businesses that you could
build that make blockchain and digital
assets more valuable the winklevoss
twins did that really well after the
facebook settlement they took 11 million
dollars they dollar cost it into crypto
not even other costs they really just
bought bitcoin below 100
today those holdings are worth billions
of dollars but they didn't stop there
they could have stopped there they're
not multi-billionaires but they built
gemini a compliant and regulated
cryptocurrency exchange
that is a fiat to crypto on-ramp that
has millions of users and that made
their own holdings more valuable so when
i say accumulation accumulation is great
that's the first day but the last three
a is awareness adoption for us that's 1
800 bitcoin building awareness helping
make bitcoin and blockchain a less
intimidating subject building on-ramps
access helping people access in a
compliant way these regulated crypto
markets and adoption we ourselves are
young native platform builders building
platforms native to many blockchains
like the hedera network like solana like
ethereum and nfg.com aspires to get lots
of users and have them use blockchains
in some cases not even know that they're
using it so you know you spoke about a
million dollar bitcoin that is
absolutely within the realm of what's
possible here just given one i think
where we are
in the adoption curve if you look at the
adoption curve of bitcoin versus the
adoption curve of the internet we've got
to be in 1994 and 1995 just in terms of
sheer number of people that are on these
networks uh the actual adoption curves
if you look at the charts are are quite
similar so we think it's very early gold
is what a 10 11 trillion dollar market
cap and to take paul tudor jones's words
uh he describes this in a white paper as
even better than gold so if it's better
than gold i think we'll talk about a
market cap even bigger than that so half
a million to a million is absolutely
within the realm of what i think is
possible in this ecosystem
now uh kevin o'leary i want to ask you
because jordan just talked about gemini
gemini has a gemini coin a stable coin
and that's uh backed by a dollar and a
bank account somewhere that's fdic
insured but a lot of folks who hold the
gemini coin do so so they can earn
yields five six seven eight percent on
their stable coin and they see this as
almost a high-yield savings account but
a lot of them aren't familiar that when
they opt into that sort of uh yield what
they're really doing is they're lending
out their coin and so concerns have come
up that how many times are these gemini
coins or stable coins being lent out uh
and if they're being rehypothecated over
and over and over again is there a
potential that the crypto market is 10
20 x as leveraged as a traditional
finance or is that not so much of a
concern kevin o'leary what's your take
on that
no i mean you're raising an issue around
stable coins there are other stable
coins obviously usdc included tether
the regulator has uh spoken onto on this
issue just only three weeks ago
regarding the concept that stable coins
are you know being treated like money
market funds when you for example sell
your stock in a traditional brokerage
account very often you're swept into a
money market fund while it weights in
cash and maybe you're yielding today 23
24 basis points but
that is backed by
dollars and very short duration
government credits in most cases
and the same issue is being debated
around stable coins and so what i
anticipate happening because you're
right the reason that let's just take
usdc one that i'm more familiar with
because i actually use it corporately at
cr you know managed by circle
um they've been growing 10x every year
they started with 100 million and today
there's over 30 billion dollars worth of
usdc
and yet it hasn't been adopted
institutionally yet there are some high
net worth family offices hedge funds
that do stake it or lend it as you
suggested and the current yields on that
are around 5.8 to 6.4 percent and i know
that because i just signed three more
stakes this morning and i'm using the
circle platform to do that now it's it's
not a huge amount of dollars because
we're still in the
i was the one of the first business
accounts that they opened as a pioneer
to help get that going and it took me
six months to get my own internal
compliance department on board and
another two months to get my external
auditors to sign my statements that then
i could fulfill my obligation to
regulators in various geographies where
we're using this strategy
and so we are nowhere yet on stable
coins in terms of it becoming an
institutional product the most likely
scenario in my view and it's a personal
opinion
is that
circle who has the 30 billion will end
up being licensed as a bank
and have to comply the same way banks do
to their money market accounts and that
would solve a lot of problems
it would allow me to go to a full
weighting
of usdc right now to get it through my
compliance i have to treat it like a
stock it's not a stock it's a it's a
proxy on the us dollar and yet i can't
get my own compliance people to agree so
we're very nascent in this process very
very early but the fact that i'm going
through all of these headaches is
because you're right i can make six
percent
and i can't do that anywhere else and i
and i have to make something over 2.1
because that's inflation so there's a
lot of interest here if you like that
video where did you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe